welcome back to street talk
today's episode is going to be presented
by my partner in crime
mit phd dr keith duggar
go ahead keith the concept of
probability as something more than a
frequency
reaches far in human history the ancient
greek philosophers referred to
icos which socrates described as
likeness to truth which set it apart
from truth
which to socrates was only that which
could be deductively proved
by logic yet our journey towards a more
general concept
began with frequencies and games of
chance
as gambling has long enthralled our
species
for 2 000 years after socrates time
humanity inched its way slowly through
logic and mathematics
until the mid 1600s when the great
french mathematicians
fermat and pascal put forward the
beginnings
of a modern mathematical theory of
probability
over the next 100 years probability
pushed
a little bit forward to problems of
so-called inverse probability
helped along by none other than bayes
himself
finally in the early 1800s laplace
generalized probability beyond the scope
of gambling
to scientific inference where it reigns
supreme to this day
even at the most fundamental bedrock of
the universe
and perhaps even of mathematics itself
as james clark maxwell of physics fame
said
the true logic of this world is to be
found
in the theory of probability
given the hard-won progress of human
thinking to rise
from frequencies and games of chance to
a more general
and more powerful concept of probability
why then do we seem to slide backwards
in the early 1900s
only to slowly recover at the turn of
the century
i think there are two important drivers
for that
first solving actual models of physical
systems can be hard if not impossible
just look to the many simplifying
assumptions or system
simplifications required to find
solutions
in for example general relativity or
quantum mechanics
when we deploy probability theory's
logic it often demands of us
computations that we simply could not
realistically perform
in those early decades of the 20th
century
so applied mathematicians and scientists
naturally turned to simplifications they
could calculate
i.e they turn to statistics
second at the same time a dominating and
belligerent according to some
personality arose in the field in the
form of british
statistician and geneticist sir ronald
fisher
the useful application of statistics to
his field of genetics
combined with the force of fisher's
personality created a gravity well that
sucked entire generations of scientists
into a limiting frequentest orbit
of course as fellow british statistician
and chief executive of the alan turing
institute
sir adrian smith put it any approach
to scientific inference which seeks to
legitimize and answer in response to
complex
uncertainty is for me a totalitarian
parody
of a would-be rational learning process
in other words at some level
of complexity at some level of reality
statistics is doomed to break down and
force us
up to the mathematics of uncertainty
itself in other words
probability theory and its tools of
analysis
such as bayesian analysis
this is why many practitioners such as
connor alex and myself
are ultimately driven to bayesian
analysis to surmount the many practical
challenges that confound the limited
scope of statistics
such as model selections small sample
size few shot learning
combining experiments incorporating
prior knowledge
non-normal models etc etc
luckily the development of bayesian
methods over the last century
hasn't entirely stagnated new
theoretical
developments in such fields as
information theory differential geometry
and even theoretical physics as well as
the advanced and applied methods such as
kernel methods
empirical bays and markov chain monte
carlo
combined with ever greater computer
power at our fingertips
have finally set the conditions for
bayesian methods to rise again
and indeed thrive over the next century
we hope you enjoy the ride hello machine
learning street talk
i'm dr duggar and together with my
compadres dr
tim velocity video scarf
and alex bayesian social stem lake
and then our guest corner today we have
connor tan
welcome to the show connor hello thank
you so much for having me
so connor is a physicist and senior data
scientist working for a multinational
energy company where he co-founded
and leads a data science team he
specializes in the application of
machine learning models with a
particular passion
for probabilistic models and everything
bayesian
he holds a first class degree in
experimental and theoretical
physics from cambridge university with a
masters in particle
astrophysics of all things as we are all
bayesian enthusiasts here we are going
to
probably take the opportunity to go deep
down the rabbit hole but you never know
on many important subjects
in the bayesian arena for example model
selection
one of its most important applications
so yeah connor welcome to the show
ah thank you so much i mean so tell us a
bit about your uh
your interest in bayesian methods you
know i mean how did you how did you come
to those if you will
in this in this era i think i'm probably
quite a late convert actually so i think
like a lot of scientists i was taught
frequentist all through
education i learned general statistical
methods
um hypothesis testing and
t-tests and so on and then get into the
real world
um it was hard it was so hard to make
all of these approximations
work it was so hard to predict the
things i was trying to predict
um i think probably my first exposure
was
working with a really really great
colleague a physicist called anjum
who would write these reports and
when i expected some kind of hypothesis
test to happen he'd always have
something about sampling and some markov
chain monte carlo and a burn-in period i
had no idea what on earth was going on
um and then his results always matched
much much better with
kind of common sense than what i've
recommend this thing
i approach would lead and so that got me
interested
and i was several years ago and
now it's just i guess my eyes were
opened
i saw the light um so you were you were
really driven by
by practical considerations you were
just trying to solve problems
and the tool set that you had wasn't
working out for that
and that's kind of what pulled you into
this bayesian arena fair to say
that's exactly it i think it was also um
working with small data sets
that was really the key right so where
where there were cases where i had very
little data
and a lot of physics based knowledge a
lot of science that tells me what should
be going on and i just need some way to
combine
multiple sources of information i'm
going to be asking all the dumb
questions today
but can you explain to us like we're
five
what the benefits are of bayesian
approaches
definitely okay so i think the biggest
benefit
is being able to capture your prior
beliefs i mean
using a probability function so for lots
of times when
you see new data and you immediately
forget everything you know about the
world and you try to analyze just what
that little bit of information is saying
but most of the time you care way more
about the full picture you've got lots
of fast experience
and so doing your knee-jerk reaction of
just
kind of myopically focusing on the new
data i gives you the wrong result and
that's what
asian stats gives you over traditional
methods that helps you
kind of use your common sense bring
everything you can to the table
everything you've seen before and
make the most of your new data as well
there is an interesting continuum though
right because
um if you just want to get stuff done
the frequency methods just give you an
answer
and with these um bayesian methods you
you get
more information you get confidence
intervals for example
but in practice is that useful you get
you get confidence intervals with
frequency methods too
it's just um the interpretation of those
confidence intervals
aren't always as naturally interpretable
as they are with bayesian
um like credible intervals or you know
just a
a histogram of your posterior on on that
so if you make bare predictions with a
frequency method let's say a support
vector machine or something
or even a neural network you you get an
output and typically you scale the
output you might use a sigmoid
activation or something so you might
you might get a number between naught
and one and it's a little bit weird
isn't it because you get these kind of
um asymptotic um flattening
edges on either side of the function and
you could make the argument that
if it's a binary classifier and you want
to say yes or no
then the closer it is to one the more
confident you are
but that doesn't really work very well
and there are approaches like there's
something called the transductive
confidence machine which is a way to
introduce
confidence measures into traditional
machine learning methods
and they compute a measure of
strangeness and you you compute
multiple predictions and then you run it
through something that looks a bit like
the bayesian function to give you these
confidence intervals
but i would argue that with these
traditional methods you don't really
have confidence intervals
well let me point out something which is
because you you mentioned kind of
and i'm even forgetting what you called
it now but some transduction whatever
you know i think
the important thing that i or a point i
want to make is that that's all
arbitrary hacked stuff okay like
just think about in the machine learning
world when somebody comes along goes
hey i'm going to add this cool new layer
that nobody's ever thought of and wow
look at that it works great that's
you know it's just a total hack that
they pulled out of thin air or maybe
they tried a thousand different things
and then
you know only magically shared the one
that that worked you know the
interesting thing about
the bayesian approach is it's derived
straight from
probability theory i mean it's just if
you take
the product rule the probability theory
the conditional product rule right which
which says
the probability of a and b so the
you know the logical conjunction of a
and b
it's equal to the probability of a given
b
times the probability of b that's it
that's the product rule and actually
just from that rule alone just by
swapping the symbols you automatically
derive
bayes theorem right i mean to deny for
example bayes theorem is just to deny
the product rule which is which is a bit
of a problem because nobody denies the
product rule right
and the product rule automatically gives
you this capability to chain
if you will or to you know reason about
multiple sets of data like conor was
saying you know
if we know that this distribution is
exponential
or something weird based on a on a
physical model
how do i incorporate that knowledge you
automatically get that capability
through the product rule
of probability theory and so the unique
thing about that approach is
it's the only one for which we actually
have a very firm
agreed upon mathematical basis as
opposed to people coming along and
saying
oh dude do batch norm because it
magically works or something but we
don't really have any theory for why
that works
i've got to say though in defensive
hacks i think there are so many things
that
um machine learning engineers have done
just because it works we don't really
understand why
it works and sometimes retrospectively
you can then derive them as actually if
it's a
if you take a bayesian framework you can
reason why this is the right thing to do
i think my favorite example is
vectorization
so suppose you're fitting a big linear
regression model for example and you've
got all these terms
and your model is really over fitting
the data
so what you do you know you think well
you know curve fitting says that this
is my best equation but i'm just going
to dampen down all the parameters i
don't really want any large numbers so
i'm going to
just add an extra term you know some of
this some of the
squares of all the coefficients in my
model and that's just going to give me a
model that uses
fewer you know predictive variables it's
going to be a simpler model
and i just reckon that's going to
generalize a bit better um well that's i
think that's how it first gets
that old there's that old saying you
know if it works it's probably because
it's busy bayesian deep down
but uh deep down i think that's probably
just a bit of
you know bayesian elitism coming in you
know the bayesian ball
absorbing all you know models as a
special case of their own
but but you that case said that
if you have a prior um so regulation
you can derive that if you assume it's a
gaussian fire over your variables right
if you the l2 norm corresponds having
gaussian fire i think having an l1 norm
is a
laplacian right but even even on that
because
you could argue that regularization
sometimes it's enforcing a simpler model
sometimes it's just making it harder to
learn
like with dropout in deep learning
models you're you're just randomly
zeroing things off during training
well that that's well there's a
fundamental problem that that we're
trying to solve
is this requirement that you have to do
these
unsolvable integrals you know they tell
you that
if you really want to solve your problem
you have to conduct this marginalization
and we can't you know they're these like
vast multi-dimensional integrals or
they're
even worse they're mixed integer
integrals or combinatorial integrals and
so like you're bringing out dropout
layers
you know the problem is that we can't do
the integral that would tell us
look you only need these 17 nodes
out of the 100 that you're sort of uh
having in that layer or something and so
we just sort of randomly
explore that space and try to find it
but ultimately it comes down to the fact
that we can't conduct these
these integrals um efficiently just on
that subject of priors
we spoke to max welling recently and he
made the comment that there
are always assumptions in all models
there are always priors
even in the kind of frequentest models
that we use like deep learning models
there's this bias there's aspires
variance trade-off
right and he was saying that if you
introduce more inductive priors then it
actually makes the approach a little bit
more sample efficient
because you're basically making
assumptions about the type of data that
you're going to
experience it's not so different to the
bayesian methods
but there are some interesting things
because you said well at some point
everything is bayesian and that's
certain it
certainly seems to be the case with
let's say kernel ridge regression
right which is a kernelized and
regularized form of least squares
and it turns out that you can do this
gaussian process thing right
um why are they equivalent well a
gaussian process
isn't necessarily equivalent to
kernel ridge regression it's just if you
start from kernel ridge regression
it's possible to get closed form
estimates of your uncertainty
and like really okay let's let's
put on the stack this idea of
uncertainty and base
um because that's kind of the practical
upshot of bays
but kernel ridge regression estimating
the mean
function from memory uh is the same in
gaussian process
it's kernel ridge regression in a
gaussian process gives you the mean
function
but there's also this measure of like
what you don't know
and that's that's where it gets
different from traditional ridge
regression
um the way that that's calculated is
is different and and admittedly there
are ways where if you have a linear
kernel it is the same
thing as bayesian ridge regression and
you avoid cubic calculations it's all
much neater but then you don't get the
nice non-linear stuff
and you know the universality of the
gaussian kernel and stuff like that
so funny you mentioned gaussian
processors i guess it turns out in
business we often care a lot more
about the uncertainty in their
prediction than the actual prediction
itself
so there are many times when a
you know one particular model might give
you the best possible answer for
something like a gaussian process that
can really neatly describe you know give
you a standard deviation on
at any given point really nicely
summarize the
uncertainty it's just so more useful for
decision making
it's important to realize how how much
the language of of
a frequent you know view has kind of
permeated you know through all the
concepts that we talk about for example
the idea of bias to begin with
is not a bayesian concept it's like when
you do
what bayesian tells you is that if you
have a model and you go and collect some
data
okay after you collect that data the sum
total of
everything you know every iota of
information that can come from that data
is actually represented as a
distribution
not as a number not as a statistic not
as an
estimate right those are all you know
you end up with this distribution that
tells you
everything the totality of all the
knowledge you have and when you reduce
that to a number to a statistic
ie to a function of it that's when you
cross over into the world of statistics
and you start to get into all these
issues of like well this
one magic number that i chose from this
distribution like the mean
or the mode right or the median has all
these
issues right yeah because you've taken
the information and you've compressed it
into a single
a single estimate and so like what
conor's getting at there is that
you know in business you care a lot more
actually usually about that distribution
of knowledge and how that can affect
your you know your outcomes considering
different scenarios
than you do about just one particular
arbitrary you know summarization
of that distribution let's um let's work
through an example of that i mean in a
second
economy great for you to introduce what
gaussian processors are but
the what we're talking about here though
is that with kernel ridge regression
it would predict a number given
a signal and with gaussian processes
as well as having the actual number
which is basically the the mean or the
mode of this distribution
we also have some measure of how certain
we are and you asserted connor that
that's
super useful so can you give me an
example of when that's super useful
i think often it comes when you have
the ability to collect more data in
future and you're trying to understand
where do i take new measurements if i'm
um
or do i even need to and so it comes to
in
informing decisions where you're
especially if you're a scientist or
engineer you're
trying to model something having a most
likely estimate of any given property
really doesn't help you with very much
at all if you if you don't know if you
can trust it
um and you don't know if you need to do
more work to refine that estimate so
i think in um in my career so far the
probably the
biggest impact has been in understanding
how we can target
future data collection by looking at
where there is large growth for
right and how you can combine disparate
experiments right like you have one
experiment that gives you an estimate
with this range and a completely
different experiment that gives you a
different range
you know how do you how do you combine
those you need a mathematics to combine
those
and that mathematics is probability
theory so am i am i getting that so the
most important reason is
we might have irregularly sampled data
and it gives you an indication of first
of all it's more efficient because it
means we don't need to uniformly sample
there might be some areas where we're
not so sure where we need to focus our
energy
and keith you are saying that there's
also a compositionality
component here yeah yeah so something
that's often
like not well understood people people
come across a
prize and they think oh you know well
we're just kind of injecting our
subjective
knowledge and blah blah blah you know
you're biasing your results
but really it's it's not just you know
subjective knowledge it's things like
what do we already know so that can be
the outputs of a previous experiment you
can use it to update your results
you can also extend this to this kind of
wild
class of um extended models
called hierarchical models where you
assume say
the the classic example here and
apologies to
anyone out there that are that's sick of
this example but it's probably the most
intuitive one it's called the eight
schools example and
okay the experiment looks like this we
want to
design an educational initiative we want
to we want to figure out if a program
uh helps kids improve their grade right
and we test it in eight schools now
we want to know we we know that schools
aren't the same we know that schools are
in different locations
maybe some of them are better funded
than others we don't expect the result
to be the same
across all of these schools in classical
statistics we can kind of address this
in one or two ways we can say okay let's
just pull it all together
and get some mean estimate of response
right or you can go
you can treat each school individually
and not really
um and not really have any way to
generalize
beyond these schools it will be an
accurate model but it won't generalize
well
it turns out within bayesian statistics
you can view these schools as kind of
drawn from a distribution of schools
and in that sort of framework and this
is a very natural extension you just
sample from a distribution of school and
then sample your students out and
maximize the likelihood of that model
and um and then what that really allows
you to do is kind of get
an in-between result where information
is shared between
schools right to an extent
philosophically what we're saying or
sorry more mathematically what we're
really saying here is originally we
assumed there was a standard deviation
of zero
between our schools when we do our full
pooling we assume there is no difference
between them standard
deviation is zero when we don't compare
at all
that's equivalent to the standard
deviation is like infinite
case if we relax to that very large
sort of nice area in between zero and
positive infinity
then we get this this natural extension
that shares information and allows
estimates in one school to constrain
estimates in other schools
thereby lowering our uncertainty across
the board well not necessarily lowering
our uncertainty but probably quantifying
it
giving us a good idea of if if we were
to
extend this program to a new school what
our range of outcomes would be
that probably incorporates the
uncertainty across
the schools that we have and the
uncertainty within the schools cup take
that was a
that was a long one sorry that's a great
example it reminds me of um
i think the famous misinterpretation of
statistics
in america i think it was about class
sizes i'm sure you've heard
out of this one already um tell us
the uh there was a phenomenon that
schools in rural areas areas well they
had all the best performing schools all
the students that had the
best average grade ones that got you
know the biggest percentage of students
getting into the best universities
they would tend to be in these rural
areas and so there was racking the heads
why could this be
is it something in the era is it is it
getting outdoors is that nature
is it small class sizes could that be it
um
and there was lots of government policy
to try and um
like make more schools like like these
schools
and then people also eventually realized
that the worst performing schools
were in these rural areas as well
and it was just about small class sizes
and if you if you take the kind of naive
approach that alex was referring to if
just
treating the schools is completely
independent then it's quite easy to
reach a
very misleading conclusion but if you
build a proper hierarchical model
um and you create you know calculate
some credible intervals
um you recognize the fact that there's
just going to be a lot more variation
in the smaller class sizes that's why
they've got
lots of the best classes what's the
worst just because they're more variable
because if there's a smaller number of
students
um and then you realize there's nothing
at all going on about being rural or
urban
it's just about um yeah that
this might be a good thing to contrast
with frequentest approaches so you're
you're saying that in rural areas
classes
with which are small are more variable
so if i was a frequentist model
presumably i would just incur a lot of
error because there's so much
uncertainty there
i would make a lot of mistakes whereas
with the bayesian approach
you would realize that there's a lot of
uncertainty there and that would be a
cue for you as a data scientist to kind
of double click on that uncertainty
and look for more information yeah
that's right so it is very possible you
know to model that all correctly with a
frequentist
view there's nothing stopping you from
doing that i think it's
um the bayesian approach leads itself
more naturally to
handling that kind of hierarchical
situation yeah that you can formulate it
in terms of like a mixed effects model
and you know it will work but
philosophically it doesn't make a lot of
sense
um and i guess i
i guess it really comes down to that
idea of are we to start from a blank
slate every time or are we going to
incorporate something we know about the
structure of the problem
and if you're incorporating things that
you know about the structure of the
problem and
inevitably you are you know you're
choosing a linear model you're
incorporating information about
um the problem then uh
you you quickly find yourself
philosophically in bay's land
and and you kind of have to lean into
that if if you don't then you're kind of
like
you half the time with frequent stuff
anyway you're you're invoking
multiverses or you know
infinite reruns of history to justify
the extinction whether or not the
extinction of the dinosaurs happened
um but well right and so it's it's it's
no it sounds dumb but like how you can't
explain non-repeating events within uh
within a frequency's framework whereas
bayes handles it naturally
go and give us an example so one of the
classic
one of the classic examples of this um
so i think one of the first real
bayesians if you will um and i think we
should keep in mind that
bayesian statistics if you will or
really probability theory was the first
con
was the original concept of probability
theory okay it wasn't until
you know r.a fisher with his sort of
dominant personality and belligerent
kind of attitude
everybody you know forced kind of
generations of scientists to fall into
the kind of
frequentest you know mindset right so
but
way back when uh one of the first kind
of you know people applying
these rules to science was laplace okay
and so when he went
and say estimated for example you know
the uh
the the mass of saturn or whatever it
was and he ended up with a with a
distribution for that well the mass of
saturn lies between x and y with with a
chance okay to him that just meant that
his state of knowledge the certainty of
his state of knowledge was this
this confidence interval right and to
try and imagine some type of
ensemble in which that's a frequency you
have to
try and imagine well you know and and
some multiverse like uh
95 percent of time saturn has a mass
that falls within
within this range right because that
range is larger than whatever your
experimental error is
on your telescopes or whatever you're
measuring that
that variance is there because of
physical sort of considerations and
modeling and uncertainty right not not
error
there's no error source that gives you
that range and there's no
reasonable ensemble in which that range
is a frequency
it's a state of knowledge and you can
take this extreme even further so
um you know richard cox a physicist um
i think an american physicist wrote a
paper long ago in like
40s or something which was this
fantastic
very objective look at the difference
between
frequentist and kind of you know
probability is a state of knowledge
thing
and you can go so far as to consider
constants like scientific constants like
say the fine structure constant you know
if we have an experiment that says it
lies within this range
and another one that that says it lies
within this range and we have this
confidence interval
what are we imagining some ensemble of
universes in which like this
mathematical construct this quantum
mechanical thing like takes on different
different values right of course not
like it's just it just doesn't work
there there are definitely um
contexts where the frequency approach
makes perfect sense
like if you want to calculate the
outcome like if you're gambling sure
right one of the great
one of the great hobbies of all
probabilists throughout history gambling
um frequentest inference makes great
sense because
you know you start another game and
there's your there's your repeated
outcome
you do this again and again with respect
to you know rolls of the dice or
draws the drawers of cards it makes
perfect sense
completely but bayes isn't really a way
of estimating statistics so much as it
is
a lot a logical framework for updating
one updating one world state to another
and you can do that in the context of
one event you don't need to define a
probability
in an infinite run of events you can
just have a single event there
whereas frequentest um frequent
statistics to kind of
do away with the prior kind of has to
assume this infinite run and
these limits which is fine but it does
break down
in in that sort of weird middle ground
where n is less than you know a couple
of hundred thousand
what do you mean going from one world
state to another because
my understanding is you're updating your
prior beliefs
yeah sure but like okay um we can do
this in terms of single flips of coins
right uh is i i have a coin in my hand
say
and is this a fair coin we're going to
start by assuming that it is a fair coin
we have a model of
you know the probabilities of fair coin
we flip it we observe something
and then um you know in the beginning
we're probably
going to have a fair belief that it's a
fair coin
and so one single flip is not going to
affect our posterior probabilities too
much
however if i keep flipping this coin
and heads is coming up about 80 of the
time
then over time our beliefs will shift
away from this being a fair coin
to being a a biased sampling process
and you know we can do that instance by
instance we don't need to look at
hundreds at a time and then get some
kind of measure of central tendency we
can just
in a simple problem like this we can
just directly update the the posterior
in like uh
we won't go into conjugacy but basically
because it's the same form
of a particular model that's a nice easy
one we just bump up a number
by one and and our posterior is updated
so great example actually i think of how
a bayesian approach
gives you a more common sense answer
that's just easier to interpret than a
frequentist one so if you're
flipping coins and you want to work out
is this coin biased
well in a frequentist point of view you
can work out
what is the probability that i
falsely claim that it is biased even
though it's not actually biased
a type one error whereas an asian
interval will tell you the probability
that it that is first whether or not i
assert it's fast or not it's just a lot
more
related to what i actually care about
could you talk us through the intuition
here so
let's say we start off with a binomial
distribution which is just a kind of
binary distribution of heads and tails
we start off reasonably believing that
the coin is fair
so it's it's uniform and then you do a
bunch of trials
with this unfair coin and i mean talk me
through this so
you're measuring it and at some point it
kind of converges on something which
doesn't look fair anymore
and you update your beliefs and i think
one of the
the ideas of bayesian approaches is
parsimony so with
not many trials you should be able to
reason about
your belief that it's unfair and how
unfair it is so how does that work
well let me let me this is one of my
favorite that's one of my favorite
examples
okay so i want to field this for a
minute okay because so fair coin
all right so the model is we we have the
stochastic process right
and it and it's like you said it's this
bernoulli process we're sampling it now
either it gives us heads and tails
equally with a probability of
one half okay
or it doesn't by which i mean it gives
us
heads and tails with some other
probability somewhere in the range
between
zero and one right so the
the hypothesis or the statements we're
trying to figure out here
are the probability that f exactly
equals one-half
or the probability that it equals
something else between zero and one
now if you google right now anyone out
there google fair coin
and i bet i hope after this video the
the web page doesn't get corrupted or
you know
hacked or something but if you google
right now for a fair coin
and go to the wikipedia article and read
the article on fair coin
nowhere in that entire article does it
have
probability f equals one-half the entire
discussion is about
what's the distribution of f does it lie
between this range and that range why
because frequentists have no
tools by which to answer this very
simple question of comparing two models
model one has no free parameters it's f
equals one half
model two has this free parameter f
which can be any value between
zero and one right this is what we're
trying to answer we're not trying to
figure out
what's the probability that i flip 256
heads in a row
you know if it's one half what's the
probability that f lies in some range
we're trying to answer this very what
seems to be a very simple
comparison is it one half or does it lie
somewhere between
zero and one and a bayesian framework
gives you a tool set to answer that
but you have to do this integral you
know so if you know everybody knows the
equation like all right
if i've got uh h heads and and t
tails then the probability distribution
of
f all would agree like a frequency and a
bayesian would all agree
that that probability distribution is
proportional and here f
is the fraction of heads it's
proportional to f to the h
times one minus f to the t okay
everybody agrees that's the likelihood
function
okay now what do you do with that well
bayesian tells you
okay if i'm comparing these two models
and one has a free parameter i have to
marginalize that free parameter
i.e i have to conduct this integral
integral from zero to one
of that equation right and you can do
that integral i think it's called like
euler's integral
or something and you need to have a a
prior for f
right and you can choose whatever
uniform prior
jeffrey's prior you know
box and towels prior which is like the
square root of jeffries whatever you
want okay it's not going to make a big
difference it's going to amount
somewhere between
having measured a single data point and
no data points
okay prior to this experiment if you
will so you conduct this integral and
you get this thing which is a bunch of
factorials
okay and that actually gives you the
probability
that it's not equal to one-half
versus one-half you can calculate this
and you get a number and every time you
collect a data point
that number changes and you can do
something very simple which is to say if
that's less than 50 percent in other
words it's more likely
that is biased or not biased you can
come to a conclusion about whether the
coin is
is fair or biased and my point is that
you know
p values and all that kind of stuff do
not answer this question
they don't answer that question and
frequencies don't have
a toolbox to answer that question that
reminds me of
uh i think it was the hypothetical
thought experiment that uh bayes first
proposed i think to
explain beta's theorem and why was
needed very similar working with a
binomial distribution um but you
considered a
pool table where you had a game that
would play and you'd roll a ball
a a black ball onto the pool table and
you wouldn't
look at where it landed then you'd uh
you wouldn't worry about the the pockets
the holes you assume the ball stays on
the table somewhere
and then you roll a series of red balls
onto the table
and you might say if if a given red ball
falls to the right
of the black ball then i get a point but
if the ball rolls to the left
of the black ball then you get a point
um
so a very simple game and you know you
can i guess you can
work out quite quickly that the
probability of winning a point
is just a fraction of how far along
table is the initial black wall
so if the black ball starts in the
middle it's a fair game
if the black ball starts off 90 to the
right
then one person is a lot more likely to
win the next points than the rest
what are the assumptions there so for
example is there a distribution of
velocity that i hit the assumptions
there is that
uh a ball just gets placed uniform
randomly from left to right
oh sorry i thought you meant it again it
got hit nah there's no collisions no
pockets we're just
randomly throwing balls into a tape so
the interesting question is um
let's say we've played a few rounds of
a few points and let's say i've won
two points or maybe i've won yeah two
points and you've won
one point and that's all you know so you
haven't actually seen the balls you
don't know where they've landed you just
know that i've won the first two points
and you've won
one what's the chance that i win the
next the next point
and so most people my common sense just
think well you know maybe conor's won
twice as many points so maybe it's like
two-thirds to him
you know if i've won 99 points and
you've won zero you're very confident
i'm going to win the next one because
that black ball must be all the way over
in in my corner that initial first
blackball
and this is analogous to what keith was
saying before when he said oh
frequentest would just say it's 0.5 well
it goes back to actually
what alex's point earlier on on
conjugate there's a
there's a lovely solution to it so you
got instinct often says well i'll just
maybe just
add up our scores and you know conor's
his corner score to fight by the total
that's his chance of winning
tim says tim's scored divided by the
total
um but that breaks down when you haven't
got many
points like what happens if i've won one
point and you've won zero
am i 100 likely to win the next point
that doesn't really make sense you know
you've got very little data
so instead if you solve it with the base
and when i do
you can say well i'm going to assume
that the black ball is somewhere
you know uniform distribution and then
it's a very
simple example um i'm just going to
update that distribution
you know slightly towards corner or
slightly towards tim with every ball
volt
and it's a really neat solution you can
you can model it as a beta distribution
which is just
a distribution between naught and one
that can be kind of swing one way or
from the other way
um and the um
the answer it's as if we were just to
add one to both of our scores
and then use that old approach so if
i've got one point and you've got zero
points
then the way i work out my chance of
winning is i take
y square plus one and your score plus
one so it's
two to one and i've got a two two-thirds
chance of winning this ball so you can
do it in your head
is it that easy yeah and by the way
that's exactly what i
when i kind of said earlier that a good
prior is worth maybe one data point
it's exactly this that i'm talking about
which is a lot of times if you choose
ignorance priors and let me say up front
that that quantifying
ignorance is is a very difficult problem
there's a lot of unknown you know a lot
of ongoing research about how to do that
effectively so
so i'm not saying this is a solved
problem but it's not a problem we should
sweep under the rug and ignore which is
what sort of like
you know frequencies would do right they
just ignore it and make some assumptions
and don't tell anybody
let me just finish here but i said if
you use these kind of ignorance priors
what you often end up with is exactly
what conor's talking about there
which is they have this kind of
conjugacy in the sense that
that prior is equivalent to some number
of data samples that you
that you might have observed like in the
case of the coin you know the
the bernoulli trials the coin flipping
if you use um
a completely kind of ignorant prior
which is this weird like
you know improper one over f one uh one
over
f times one minus f so the reciprocal of
what you would see in like the euler
integral
you know with one data point each um uh
that thing forces you to observe
that heads and tails are actually
possible like it assumes that it might
be possible that the coin is just
two-sided heads or two-sided tails and
you need proof
that that's you know not the case
whereas
you know you can get to kind of the
uniform prior which is what connor
you know the result there is that it
adds one to to both of the data points
so it's kind of equivalent to having
observed
um you know that that you that you would
achieve
at least a head and a tail so that a
head and tail was possible
so the priors have like this you know
very kind of minor effect in one sense
which is they're worth just a few
a data point or two or or something like
that right
if they're if they're good and we're
talking about ignorance priors
but the really cool thing is kind of
what you said tim which is well what
happens if i know if there's a
distribution on the velocity like when
when a person throws the ball
they're doing so with a certain velocity
okay like how do i incorporate that
well guess what you know you need a tool
set to do that a mathematical tool set
to do that
and the bayesian framework gives you
that tool set it lights
it lets you incorporate all these kind
of waco models like here's my velocity
model and
here's a trajectory thing and you know
it can be complicated
and then it gives you the tools to to
compute with that
it may be a very difficult computation
you may not be able to do it on
computers without a bunch of
approximations
but you at least have a tool set to
incorporate that prior knowledge
so i'm going to ask a couple of dumb
questions because i'm the only
non-bayesian here
now with the beta distribution it
sounded like you were saying
i'm gonna update my beliefs around the
score
as we have new information now that
seems good because every
every time someone score updates that's
that that information
is incredibly useful but you also start
out with a uniform prior on the ball
positions
and that's a situation where if you
update that i think it would get less
accurate
because if you play five balls having a
uniform distribution we already know
that it will converge
asymptotically to that uniform
distribution so surely that's better
right and what keith was saying about
the velocity
of people throwing the ball in that's
another one of those weird situations
perhaps you can explain this conor that
we assume
it would be normally distributed and the
universe just naturally gives us these
normal distributions
why is that so it's a question so
a normal a uniform distribution between
note and one so flat line
that's you is identical to a beta
distribution with parameters one and one
so they're completely equivalent um one
reason though you might write it as a
beta distribution
is that it's very easy to update you can
skew it one way or skew it the other way
by changing those parameters
so um it may sound confusing that would
go from a uniform
to a beta but in fact it was just a
special case of a beta all along
and then when you when you have lots of
data and you have a distribution that's
very peaked um
uh i guess yeah in a sense it might look
like a normal distribution but it's
probably not going to be the
you know i think we often jump to use a
normal distribution for everything that
looks at all
curvy but sometimes that's maybe not
appropriate because a normal has a tail
that'll go to
negative can you be negative can it be
greater than one does that really make
sense
so i think it's quite nice to have in
your toolbox as a
as a practicing scientist just a bit of
a working knowledge of
really common distributions and what
that domain are so you know that a
a uniform distribution can go from one
limit to another a normal is from
negative infinity to positive infinity
a gamma is from zero to possibility
beta is between 20 numbers and with
those you can probably always
fit a distribution to any kind of prior
if you just know
what kind of means i want what standard
deviation do i want
and what what kind of limits make sense
not only is it important to have that
kind of toolbox of distributions and and
know about their ranges like conor's
pointing out
but one of the really cool things that
bayesian land kind of taught me
is all the deep relationships between
those distributions
like this distribution is the marginal
of that distribution
if you if you have this this prior that
this one you know there's a bunch of
interconnections between those
relationships
that you need the toolbox of probability
theory of bayesian analysis to to kind
of
grok those relationships and it's very
helpful at least it was
it it invokes lots of thoughts from me
as well because there are lots of
interesting relationships between
functions
when you study fourier analysis for
example you learned that
the complex exponentials are basically
trigonometric functions and
i'm sure the distributions are related
in a similar way it's a good example
yeah indeed but the thing is when we do
neural networks
we just always use the relu activation
function and
i just wondered how fractionated is it
because i would like to believe that the
universe is quite homogenous in its
stochastic generating functions and
you know i wouldn't need to go overboard
in you know
looking at all of these different
functions for doing things how
fractionated is it
i don't think the normal distribution
exists in nature nearly as much as we
think it does
so much as the log normal does um
and that's just a factor of time like
you think about the size
of say fish in the ocean would probably
be a good example
just a single species that's not going
to be normally distributed
for one it's not going to go all the way
to like negative sizes
so we can already say the assumptions of
the normal distribution don't quite
match okay so
why why might we think log normal then
well because
there's only going to be a very small
amount of very very small fish
that's actually probably going to be
exponential but whatever you know we'll
ignore that for now
there will be very small amounts of of
incredibly tiny fish
that are so small that it's birth
defects and they're probably going to
die
there's going to be a very large body of
like
spawn and then that tail is going to go
out longer and longer
until you have a very tiny number of
very large fish
and doing a sort of like a lot of
applied data analysis
um i'm more i more often see these kinds
of
exponential tails with you know some
weird behavior down the bottom that are
either gamma
or log normal or one of these sort of
zero to infinity
um distributions one of these long tail
distributions then we see the normal
distribution
the normal distribution does arise but
it tends to arise in
situations where you ignore time as soon
as you add time to things
you tend to get power laws and um
exponential tails and and all kinds of
nasty stuff that that mean
you know our nice assumptions about
gaussianity
tend to completely break down
so it reminds me of your point earlier
about how hard it is to choose a
a good prior that is uninformative i
talk about normals and
log normals um have you heard of
benefits law
it's a it came up recently and people
talking about
so memphis law is quite cool when you
first come across it
if you look at a newspaper and you just
read it write down every number you see
the date the
page number anything and you look at the
first digit
of that number you'll find way more one
twos and threes you
four then you will find seven eights and
nines
so the date i mean uh that starts with
the two
the year sorry uh the month probably
starts with a with a one
um uh i mean my height in centimeters
that starts with a one
um my age starts with a two so just
numbers in general tend to start with a
low digit
and that that's often because you can
think about it maybe as having a
you know you have a distribution a prior
that's in log space rather than a normal
space if you look at a log scale
of multiple scales a lot of that that
space is taken up with
one two three rather than 89 so the the
distribution of all numbers in the world
that we come across in life um across
multiple scales
um it's probably like
look normal distributed rather than
actual normal distribution
uh actually distributed a quick point on
that
when greece joined the eu they made up
their numbers
they wanted to make it look like they
were
economically solvent so they made up
their numbers
and presumably they used a uniform
random number generator or they just
you know made up some spreadsheets and
it was exactly that it was the golden
age it's a little bit more sophisticated
goldman sachs is a little bit more
sophisticated than the random function
in
excel i'd like to think well
that was that was the proof though that
they that they made up the numbers
yeah yeah they they use so they use
benford's law
um you know at least in some countries i
don't know about all but they do use it
for detecting tax fraud because your
digits
you know deviate from this this
distribution i think it's kind of it's
it's funny to know how
how that law was discovered which was um
this uh
canadian um astronomer i believe it was
uh simon newcomb you know back in the
day right when they wanted logarithms
they'd go look in a book so there are
these books that had tables of
logarithms so you could just kind of
look those up didn't have calculators
and he noticed that
that the pages on like the section for
one
you know were much more smudged than the
ones like later in the book
and sort of the smudging you know
decreased as you went to
larger digits like large larger leading
digits right
and so he found that there was this
distribution where you know
i think it's like the ratio between
digit
leading digit one versus two is is the
proportionality is basically
you know one over one one over one plus
one so it's like one over
you know one half as many or are twos
and then one third for three that sort
of thing it's like 1 over
n basically it's kind of the
distribution
in a continuous space and then if you
integrate it between
0 and 1 1 and 2 2 and 3 you get the the
distribution for the
the leading digits so it's essentially
like jeffrey's law like jeffrey's law
or jeffrey's prior for for ignorance if
you will
um and so you know people just
discovered this through this natural
phenomenon
of smudging the paper more like in the
in the lower digits right i mean these
are real natural phenomenon that we see
out there and it occurs with like
links of rivers masses of of fish
planets etc i mean it's kind of an
interesting deep connection
so what's the intuition that i could
understand with sizes of apple right
that the gaussian is quite
intuitive but with numbers there must be
some kind of environmental
rates rate limiting step that determines
those kind of numbers appearing in our
world what is that
so i'll give you my take on the
intuition and then let the others give
you there so
let me talk about the intuition betw
behind jeffrey's prior so jeffrey's
pryor says that
you know the ignorance distribution for
a scale parameter and it's important
here that i'm talking about like kind of
scale
is one over that scale okay so like one
over x
if or or one over you know sigma for
example a sigma is a standard deviation
why that why that well it turns out that
you know
any pow if you use that distribution for
one over sigma
uh then it's it's also the same
ignorance distribution for
one over any power of that so one if
you're using sigma squared in your
equations instead the ignorance
distribution is
also one over sigma square because if
you do the probability transformation
correctly
you'll find out that that's how one over
sigma would transform to sign a
sort of any powers so it's a scale and
variant
you know parameter and so maybe it's
saying something about
kind of the universe as a whole that it
kind of has this
scale and variance in the sense that
like whatever units
you choose for time maybe we all decide
tomorrow that we don't like
seconds anymore we're going to measure
all our data in like
60 second you know minute intervals or
something like that it doesn't matter
what scale you choose
to measure time if you the scale that
you choose to measure length is in a
sense kind of arbitrary
and so if you want to if you want to
make it to where it doesn't matter what
yardstick you're using
in lots of measurement situations
then you want to scale and variant kind
of prior and so maybe it's saying
something deep about
the universe has some kind of built-in
kind of scale and variance
i mean we know it does have like things
like lorenzen variants and other
other sort of you know scale and variant
type of properties
um and it seems to have these kind of
things that repeat
at different scales um so i don't know
the answer but
it's it's cool i think my intuition
behind that one
is that just that there's often
not a really single obvious prior
distribution that you should go for
if you if you're ignorant um i think
sometimes we have a
dj reaction that the uniform
distribution seems like just
the best thing to do if you're if you
don't know it you don't know any um
if you have no information you want to
be as ignorant as possible
um but it's got this achilles heel the
uniform distribution because it's
uniform
over what um you know over the variable
over a log of the variable over one
minus the variable
it can make a difference so one example
is this there's a
consider two factories right that both
make cubes
okay and one factor of factory a
makes cubes of length between one meter
and two meters
randomly and the second factory it
produces cubes of
volume between one meter cubed and eight
meter cubes
now are they the same factory that's the
question
so but first you might think um yeah
they're the same because you know a
cube with length two meters is the same
as the cube of volume
eight meter cube so they're the same but
then well if the first one is uniform
between one and two then the average
cube is what of length
one and a half and that's as a different
cube
to a cube of volume well four and a half
so uniform on length is not the same as
uniform and volume
and that's how you phrase the question
what you mean by randomly between one
and two
randomly we spent random with respect to
x or x squared or x cubed they're all
different
uh and so you can't i guess what i'm
my takeaway from that experiment is that
you can't just slap a uniform
distribution on it and say okay that's
my prior i don't need to think anymore
like
it it matters um but what's the benefit
because it's available the prior was the
same on both but are you saying that
it's model building it's the price
sounds the same but it's actually a
different prior
so a prior of uniform length between one
and two
is different to a prior of uniform
volume between one and eight
um so the the the reason it's a little
bit different is that
try to consider what would be in the
middle so a cube of
kind of just my head what is one and a
half to the power of three
not question but it's different to one
and a half
um so the the the second factory it
turns out on average will produce bigger
cubes than the first
and the the priors only superficially
sound the same
which is what makes that kind of a
interesting thought experiment
yeah i'm going to uh offend both our
guests and keith here
by saying pick whichever distribution
makes you a numerical integrator happy
because
you know mcmc hmc is hard enough
no look it's kind of a cop-out but if
you think of it
um if you think of it as just a
constraint on the numerical integration
so that your chains don't run forever
before you know you get a sufficient
number of samples to actually
do something with your data then um
yeah then you can motivate it with
pragmatism and
it doesn't sure it doesn't feel so much
of a cop out like
i've never understood the appeal of
scale and variance abstractly yeah
it's a cool principle but in practice
you know it's
it's scale invariant for a particular
for a particular choice of model i'm i'm
gonna
probably pick a great big normal i'm a
big fan of andrew gellman's work
um him looking at uh what he calls
weekly informative priors
which is say we scale out our data to
like
um zero one normals or you know standard
standard input scaling we subtract out
the mean divide by the standard
deviation
in theory we have our data sitting
you know with somewhere within one
standard deviation for the most part
we then put a prior with standard
deviation of like
5 or 10 over over our parameters
much bigger than we'd actually expect
the effect size to be
in that case what we're doing is we're
not saying anything specific about the
data
we're saying we think the parameter is
probably going to be normally
distributed but
we're not sure but more importantly what
we're not doing is we're not integrating
from minus infinity
to infinity now we're integrating in a
much more
targeted range and that much more
targeted range makes
makes the problem tractable if you have
some some kind of model with a weird
you know topology like like these
hierarchical models we discussed earlier
philosophically they're a fantastic idea
practically computing them is basically
the entire motivation of the stan
programming language because there's
these weird numerics when you
when you get deep down to how these
things actually work
one thing that's interesting and we were
kind of talking about just the kind of
magical theoretical
connections that were kind of quite
interesting and then you you jump to
pragmatism which i love because
because i'm a pragmatist right so what's
kind of interesting about
the kind of bayesian you know people who
come from a bayesian direction and
and head towards pragmatism it's because
they're kind of forced to think about
these integrals all the time
they essentially just go all right
forget it like i'm just going to write
down whatever kind of practical model i
can
just in some way that i can numerically
integrate it right
and the nice thing about that is it lets
you throw in
everything you know scientifically
because you can just like for example
for a long time
i would actually to every single model i
would had i would i would add to it
a uh an alternative model with a low
prior probability that was just
uniform everywhere like essentially a
five percent chance of something i never
expected happening
right because i just i found it was
important to have that anomaly
you know sort of anomalous model in
there right like here's i'm going to
allow for anomalous data points
essentially
and you can just throw in the whole
kitchen sink like almost like uh erai's
approach to you know building a general
intelligence
let's just throw in everything and then
we got to do this numerical integral
anyway and and like we kind of mentioned
earlier you know the priors
maybe they're worth one data point or
two or a half or
or whatever the the hard the important
part is the likelihood function
and doing the integrals so i'm totally
on board with that that approach but i
do like thinking about
where these sort of deep connections you
know may lie with the uh
underlying magical universe go ahead tim
well yeah i mean
that's super interesting but but it is
interesting from my point of view as a
naive bystander that i assume that a lot
of bayesian approaches are
about sample efficiency and updating
your prior beliefs and reasoning under
uncertainty and so on but
a big part of it as alex was saying is
just
wrestling with the computational
complexity of solving these numerical
integrations and these are clearly
situations where if you
increase the specificity of your prior
you're just massively cutting down the
space of possible solutions that you
need to be searching it effectively
but just with an eye on the time i
wanted to get into model building and
some of these
numerical integration approaches
oh boy that's a can of worms um
i i think for the sake of uh not
blowing out the time can we just agree
that like
variations on mcmc and sequential monte
carlo are cool
and there are various cool approaches
and then maybe move on to model building
from there because otherwise
we'll be here all night well is it
could you succinctly describe what is
going on
let's say marco j monte carlo what is it
connor do you want to do this one or i
i'm happy to give it a crack but you're
you've got the maths background
literally and metaphorically
sure i'll give that one crack um so
markov chain monte carlo
is a really cool really useful technique
but it's a bit wacky the way it works i
was surprised
when i first heard it like actually
there's a thing we have to do that
actually works but it's
it's goldust um and it
i think it's useful because often in
bayes theorem you know we have the
prior times by the likelihood divided by
the evidence
and often we can't compute the evidence
it's a maybe it's intractable
maybe it's computationally really hard
to do and so
we have this posterior distribution
where we have we know what the nominator
is but we don't know what the
denominator is
um so we we know it up to a kind of a
constant factor and
so we're most of the way there but we
can't really say how likely any
particular prediction is
but what we can do is we can compare the
relative likelihood
um and the way i think about mtmc
is that it gives you a tool to go from
an unnormalized
posterior probability distribution and
still until work with a still
get results out and so you you have a
particular regime for generating samples
and
moving to a new area and accepting or
rejecting samples
as a chain as a markov model and you can
use
a whole variety of different ways of
moving around your space of
um in your in your probability
distribution
and if you leave it running for long
enough you'll end up with
a sampling distribution that is a good
approximation for the
the full distribution um so it's a
really
useful thing to have then the challenge
that comes with that the thing that
makes it quite annoying is you can never
know for sure whether you've
run the chain for long enough something
it needs to be burnt in
and it might be for example you know
you're stuck in one particular area of
your sample space and there's a another
area you've never explored
and you can do all these diagnostics but
fundamentally you can tell when you
haven't
you know done it long enough there are
things that go wrong but it's really
hard to tell when you have
it long enough you can never be sure
that you're not missing something
enormous
this is one of the big problems i mean
with any
optimization problem multi-modality
most systems just break when they
encounter multi-modality
and i've seen some research um
a friend of mine was working on some
stuff uh involving a thing called the
shadow hamiltonian
and from how i remember him described
this is all way over my head but
from how he was describing it it's um
it was a a system designed to exploit
the energy function
which is kind of like the uh sorry the
the hamiltonian which is kind of
equivalent to the unnormalized
probability density
so like in instead of uh how do we how
do we put this
instead of um just looking at the the
ratio
of our two samples we instead model the
probability space as this unnormalized
probability density
and send our sample so to speak we
simulate it as an ode and just send our
samples swinging around this energy
surface
in random directions and that will give
us
draws from this like normalized um
probability density
but um there are there are the the point
to all of that is
there are techniques that exploit jewels
of that particular problem
to try and handle multi-modality better
but in the end
um they're just multi-modality is this
really hard problem that unless you've
got these nice unimodal distributions
that
our samplers can just walk up um
you're in the same place as everyone
else in in statistics and machine
learning um
you're abused stuck in local optima
right so i'm kind of i wonder if um
we can expand out of the kind of theory
and math just for a little bit
and i'm curious you as a practitioner
actually all of you for that matter
you know how is the kind of let's say
social context
of bayesianism these days because i
remember
so back when i was kind of let's say
more involved in the community
late 90s early maybe early 2000s
something like that
you know it was very firmly entrenched
kind of
um frequentism i mean you know
there was the kind of maximum entropy
conference you could go to
and kind of meet other other bayesians
and uh but
but kind of the bayesian approach if you
will was really
more of a niche thing in areas where you
did have small sample sizes and the
stakes were very high
so an example would be military
targeting systems
you know i can't tell you how many
people from dod funded research i ran
into at the kind of bayesian conferences
or corner table
or whatever um and i kind of got in the
sense that over the last
maybe 10 to 15 years that somehow or
another
kind of the machine learning community
has started to i don't know become a bit
more open to
the bayesian methods or more people are
taking them seriously or exploring them
i'm wondering if you can just comment a
bit on that
that if any if that if that's an actual
change or if i'm just seeing things
or kind of what the current state of
this type of thinking is
it's not just the machine learning
community um it's all through science
and i i don't want to speak too long on
on the subject because
conor's probably uh more deep into that
but um
i definitely point to things like the
replication crisis and the failure of
like um statistics as practice for the
last sort of
50 or so years as really pushing people
to look for alternatives and bayesianism
is essentially now it's computable
everyone's got a computer and everyone
can run a sampler
sure i mean sometimes it's dramatized as
a revolution that's taken over the world
but
um yeah there's definitely been a really
big shift i think in
in science i think it's a yeah it's a
good example particularly in medical
sciences where
it's really important that statisticians
can present some results in a way that
is easily understood
so going back to what we're talking
about with confidence intervals it just
makes sense
to just to share with someone a patient
interval whether
they their instinctive understanding is
is going to be of a basic interval
rather than a weird frequent interval
that we haven't trained people really
hard to
interpret it perfectly but in machine
learning i think it's a little bit
different
um i think a lot of data scientists
um you know you you can use the model
without understanding
how it works and understanding anything
about the algorithm under the hood in
the same way that you can
drive the car very safely and get to get
to work without knowing anything about
an engine works or how a clutch works
um and so i think a lot of people have
started using beta methods
just because from an applied perspective
they found out that they worked really
well and then
maybe a bit later on they might do a bit
of digging and say well what's really
going on here and why are we doing this
but definitely becoming a lot more
accepted is it
are there some areas where bayesian
approaches are more
acceptable and i would imagine that
for something like computer vision for
example asian approaches wouldn't work
very well and
i now need to update my position on that
because we spoke to max welling last
week and
they are indeed building computer vision
models using gaussian processors
but the reason they're doing that is
there are situations in computer vision
where you are irregularly sampling
images
right and you might not have access to
the entire
image data and also you might be
sampling um images irregularly or not on
gridded data
so having gaussian processors there to
to represent the image data can be
beneficial but this all seems a little
bit esoteric to me i mean presumably
most people would just use
cnns right i think so but
nonetheless even if no matter what model
you use i think
it if um you can
always fit that into a probabilistic
framework right so
bayesian statistics is kind of quite
synonymous with this normal probability
theory these days as
keith was saying so that you can you can
take any classifier that works anyway
and treat it as a
just a you know a likelihood or treat it
as a
discriminative model that gives you a
conditional probability
of y given x but no matter what you use
as your
discriminative model as your your
conditional probability
you can still overall think about a
problem in a patient context by
um you know at a as a second step
incorporating some other information and
using five probabilities
so i think it's you know there's no
reason to
you can't think like a patient whilst
using
any traditional technique yeah i think
i think that's really key i think for 90
of problems
your first pass is always frequentest if
only just because it's quicker to
calculate you can
you can quickly call some functions
calculate some central tendencies
you know you don't need to you don't
need to spend hours waiting for a
sampling process to complete
you can get some ballpark you know
high-level
summary statistics of your data enough
to kind of give you a clue of where to
look and
and what sort of model you might want to
be doing there's nothing wrong with that
there there are
certainly cases where you know you're
not going to be doing 100 dimensional
integrals
because that's just madness like that
way
that way insanity and very high cloud
compute costs lie
um so there's there's nothing wrong with
applying frequent techniques they're a
great first approximation when you need
something fast go for quentist
when you need something done properly do
it the bayesian way because that way you
get
you get the right answer you get the
right answer and the information that
you need
but generally that's the last step
yeah and i agree with you there which is
my first step
uh when i was doing kind of research if
you will was always actual
actually visual like i wanted to make
some plots you know let me plot
this by this and the cloud plot heat map
whatever in order to reduce the
dimensionality enough so that my feeble
human mind which can sort of barely
grasp maybe three or three plus one
dimensions you know could handle
i would have to do some type of first
pass
statistical summarization and a whole
bunch of different sort of plots so then
i could zero in on
oh here's some interesting structure
that maybe i can try and think about
more and
and model you know so absolutely and
actually
you know connor you'll appreciate this
the i didn't start off
knowing about bayesian things either i
was from the same you know orthodox kind
of background and
at some point in my past i was trying to
calculate the lifetime of fluorophores
from very small photos photon counts you
know like
23 photons or something that i would
collect from a
from a sample right and i was looking at
these plots of things and i could kind
of tell with my eye
what the the lifetime would be roughly
of that that fluorophore you know some
exponential decay plot or whatever but i
needed a quantitative measure for that
so i'm out looking up white papers
figuring trying to figure out how to
incorporate the prior knowledge we had
into
into this you know how many photons do
you need to measure a
lifetime of a floor for and i literally
found the paper called how many photons
do you need to
calculate the lifetime of a floor for
and it goes through this whole fissure
information
blah blah blah you know whatever
analysis and comes to some conclusion
that like you need ten thousand
and i was like well i've got like
30 or less like what do i do now
like how do i how do i do research now
and it just so happened that
that a office mate of mine and this is
one of these weird coincidences in life
i'm sitting here looking this paper
this office mate starts he's laughing
over at his desk just laughing so i'm
i'm in a dead end i get up i walk over
hey
mike uh what's so funny oh i'm reading
this book about um
you know sort of statistics and i'm just
laughing at this chapter that's talking
about how like
orthodox statistics totally breaks down
and yet you can still solve the problem
with like
bayesian maximum likelihood or something
mike can i see that book for a minute
i grab it and it's data analysis of
bayesian tutorial by
sivia and it completely changed my life
because it gave me a tool set to deal
with these small
sample count kinds of problems where i
could incorporate the physical the
physics knowledge that i had from
you know what was going on but but i'm
just saying i don't disagree with you
alex like as a first pass
visualization techniques and those
require reduction and dimensionality
go for it and then like you said when
you actually need to
model something and incorporate your
scientific knowledge into that process
and
or get the most you can out of a small
number of data points you have to
you have to embrace these tools it
reminds me of um
i think i remembered when i first heard
about bayes theorem
um in a lecture in university
um we're learning about neutrino
neutrinos which are
really cool things right there uh tiny
elementary particles
and they pass through you all the time
they don't interact very much
and um they're one of the most exciting
things to look at
for quantum particle astrophysics
because
uh they were created very early on in
the universe
so you know about the cosmic microwave
background using photons neutrinos are
even better because they let you see
even further back in time
but anyway um someone did an experiment
and they were measuring how fast
neutrinos travel
and it rocked the world it was about in
2013 also
and they realized that youtubers
actually traveled faster than light
under like a very specific circumstances
they'd
recorded it they had the data they made
a distribution and they had all their
random and systematic errors
captured i think i remember this this
was um
it's really cool right it's so exciting
we love it when
we break our previous physics models
because then we can do some more
research
yeah we love it we love it the worst
thing is when you get a result that is
exactly what you predicted because
that's so boring you can't do anything
else
um and everyone was chatting about it
and in a lecture um professor physics
was saying okay so
i'm going to show you a theory today
that explains why i will bet any money
that they've made a mistake somewhere in
their experiment
that they're wrong um even though
there's no hint of any kind of
issue with the experiment um so far um
and so you know threw it down and he
pointed at the the prior and said look
we've got
decades and decades and decades of
nothing ever going faster than speed of
light it's just so unlikely to happen
even though they've got evidence of like
the two or three sigma level
still on the balance of probabilities
much much more likely that they've just
made a mistake somewhere
um a few weeks later
it's like oh they hadn't quite plugged
in something correctly it was like it
was that bad yeah
so and he was right
yeah yeah bayesians can win a lot of
money through gambling that's
that's something to know could i touch
on something else as well because um
alex made the um the assertion that
bayesian methods are slower so only do
it if you've got lots of time and lots
of compute but
that's not always true bayesian
optimization is quite an interesting one
so if you're
searching through some parameter space
this irregular
sampling thing is really interesting
because you can just kind of focus your
effort
where you know you need to be focusing
your effort so is that an example of
where a bayesian approach will
actually improve uh the time it takes to
find the optimum parameters
well it can it can certainly so
if you're extracting more out of every
data point because you have a
you know you're able to incorporate your
physical knowledge into the situation
yeah then then you can you can
absolutely arrive at
accurate answers with say smaller sample
counts
as far as the actual computations i
think it's really just
you know let's put it this way a lot of
say frequentest results are things that
you would derive
by following a bayesian approach if you
if you made all the same assumptions
like you know i'm going to assume
gaussians and uniform priors and blah
blah and i end up with the same
you know it's telling me to do the same
calculation it's just that
in a lot of scenarios it's telling you
to do some kind of
you know nasty integral right and like
the mcmc we mentioned earlier
that's a very general purpose technique
for
sampling for sampling probability
distributions where you can calculate
the likelihood but you can't you can't
calculate the normalized
likelihood but you just you have a
function that can give you back
you know the likelihood then then it
provides you with a way of kind of
um let's say semi-efficiently sampling
you know from that distribution and
there are even ways to make it better
like if you
if you know some kind of approximation
of the distribution then you can kind of
skew the sampling that gets fed into
like the metropolis hastings sample or
the gibbs sampler or whatever and then
you can you can calculate some results
and then
unskew them you know back to what would
have happened if you'd
sort of sampled properly but they're
very general purpose techniques they're
they may be widely deployed in kind of a
amazing context because it requires you
to do these
these integrals yeah i don't know if one
of you could talk me through this
bayesian optimization example but that's
quite intuitive isn't it so i might
i have a regression model and i have six
parameters i want to optimize the
parameters to find you know to have the
lowest loss or something like that
and the alternative would be to do a
grid search and that's a fairly
exhaustive search
and i'm going to be searching and lots
of places where i don't need to be
searching
whereas presumably i could model it as a
kind of gaussian process
and i could model um some kind of
dependency between all of those
variables
i would define some sort of prior on all
of the different parameters
and that should allow me now would i
still use markov chain monte carlo for
that
i think asian optimization i don't think
that uses mcmc but
it's a really cool trick yeah if you're
building an mr model
it's great if you're doing searching
over a space of hyper parameters that's
huge
and you uh you want to be more efficient
and more
guided than just a grid search or a
random sample the the big thing there is
again a gaussian process is it's just an
interpolation technique that gives us
uncertainty so if we if we suspect that
an area may have a higher
we we don't just have to sample randomly
and hope that we explore the space
we can look at the areas where we're
most uncertain and put samples right
down there so that we can check
how that affects our predictions across
the entire space
that's kind of really the magic of
bayesian optimization
but the the computations there are still
slow
so if you were to have that on an inner
loop on
you know um we we had a bit of a giggle
a couple of weeks ago about the inner
optimization
loop on on that capsule on hinton's
capsule nets
using expectation maximization you know
if you were to do
if you were to put these calculations in
there it would suddenly get much slower
because we're putting all these very
heavy calculations in and this is kind
of where
where bays being slow is is kind of
it's kind of a misnomer it's often
quicker to get to the
answer the information that you're
looking for because you integrate things
like your uncertainty you summarize
all of your knowledge you don't just
take point estimates of it
however getting to that point where you
can make decisions where you can act
on that information yeah it is often it
is often much more difficult
and and these are the the issues of
sampling and the issues of bayesian
optimization
these are kind of two or bayesian you
know hyper parameter optimization
these are two kind of distinct beasts
that kind of need to be looked at from
different perspectives
because they involve different things i
think patient optimization
is probably the thing that's going to
get me fired
first it's going to
it's i think it's really powerful for
automated machine learning which is a
into these auto mel tools i'm sure
you've heard about that
try to automate more of the job of a
data scientist rather than just training
a classifier but maybe
the engineering maybe model selection
and uh
asian optimization is
i think a really key part of doing that
job well one of the things that humans
can
do a bit better than machines so using
asian optimization for the task of
searching over the space of different ml
models and their hyper parameters
um yes i think one of the things that's
kind of
making autumnal slowly start to catch up
with the data scientist in in that
particular
i'll give you an example of what i mean
yeah um
when when you're searching for hyper
parameters of an ml model
then you know a basic approach is a grid
search so you take
every possible combination of every
possible parameter giant grid
that's fine if it's your 2d it's like 2d
lattice
if you have 10 or more parameters they
can get really big
so then you can do a random search where
you define a
probable like a distribution over every
dimension
you want to search over and then you
just take a few take 50 samples from
that
and then try them out and score your
model based on that then bayesian
optimization
is is the next level is even better so
you
fit a gaussian process model or
something like that
on on your set of hyper parameters
and how well they've done and then
that guides you of where's a promising
space to try next
and you can trade off exploration and
exploitation so
your optimizer might say something like
well you know we've tried a lot of
vectorization and it's been quite good
but we haven't run any models with very
little vectorization so let's let's try
one or two over there um so it's a lot
more intelligent it's a lot more human
yeah and a lot more efficient if you
have a model that takes a long time to
run
like a big neural network so there are
different there are different approaches
so you could use a genetic algorithm for
example and that's a very similar thing
so it will maintain a population of
interesting parameters
you could presumably do some kind of
convex optimization but it wouldn't work
very well because you have
uh you know kind of categorical
parameters
i suppose the first point i wanted to
make is that with these automated
machine learning
solutions with classical machine
learning it's the hyper parameters
aren't that important
the algorithms aren't even that
important it's the featurization which
is the most important so
technologies like h2o the most
innovative thing they do is creating
features
so they do all sorts of different
encodings and different combinations of
features
and so on and then of course they'll try
different algorithms different hyper
parameters but it seems to be the
features which is the most important
thing
so regarding the the genetic you know
algorithm versus bayesian optimization
if if by that we're talking about kind
of classic
uh you know genetic optimization where
you you start off with some type of
random sampling
um within the the hyper parameter space
and then you sort of allow
those points to evolve right and they'll
sort of naturally approach
the local optimum that are nearest their
their kind of
starting position is that what you're
talking about like that that type of
approach
so the the advantage of the bayesian or
the the theoretical
advantage of bayesian optimization if
you will
is that because you know you have this
this
surrogate function which we haven't
talked about before but
in bayesian optimization you know what
you're doing is you're
let's say you're overlaying on top of
the hyperparameter space
a model okay and that model is this
surrogate function that we kind of think
sort of allows us to to represent the
objective function
right in that space and let's say it's a
gaussian
you know process model it's going to
have a smoothness to it
which allows the points to influence
each other
and that's kind of the hypothetical
advantage that they have over
just kind of the points wandering around
in isolation is that they can sort of
have this smooth
you know uh n squared effect on each
other because you're building up this
this um underlying model um of course
if the surrogate function is very far
from the structure of the
the objective function then it can then
it can be a hindrance
you know as well but but it just turns
out that
you know in a lot of the problems we
work on in these hyper
hyper parameter spaces they are kind of
like these multimodal
you know relatively smooth sort of
gaussian process
um systems so that that was the point i
wanted to make there
um and then as far as the feature
regularization or feature construction
goes
i don't disagree with you at all i do
just want to kind of
put a little like caveat in there which
is that
there's some arbitrariness there between
the distinction between a
feature versus a parameter because
there's a lot of models in which
the parameter space can actually define
what you might call
features elsewhere like for example
you know if i if i have a model that
allows
uh allows an unknown number of of modes
like in some type of multimodal
distribution like i have a
hyperparameter that says allow for there
to be in
gaussians like in in this mixture or
whatever you can think of those
gaussians
as features because one of them might
combine you know variables sort of in a
in a different way
to end up with what might traditionally
have been a feature so
there is a bit of a kind of general
sense
in which these are all the same thing
like hyper parameters parameters
features they can all be kind of in a
very general sense a part of a
say like a very complex model um
if you will you said they could combine
them in an interesting way but
the obvious example is computer vision
so there is a spatial
relation between the pixels and
you did so so cnn has an inductive prior
that models local connectivity between
the pixels
exactly so in the case of a great
example so say just a classic cnn and
in computer vision a channel is a
feature
right and so if i have a hyper parameter
that says
i have some number of channels six
channels 24 channels that hyper
parameter actually becomes a
feature engineering parameter if you
will because it allows itself to
introduce
you know new features in there so i just
want to say there are contexts
in which you know um in which features
can be a part or can be con
a part of the hyper parameter you know
space if you will perspective
i think you're saying they can be
expressed as a function of the hyper
parameters
yeah yeah yeah well we're nearly at time
connor do you have any advice for
aspiring data scientists that
want to get more into the the world of
bayesian
oh that's a good question um probably
the
best thing i've read in asian stats that
really helped pull everything together
for me in data science
was daphne culler who's a stanford
professor which has a
massive book called probabilistic
graphical models
and it's more of a reference thing you
wouldn't want to read it all at once
um but it really opened my eyes uh
to how everything that i'd ever learned
to machine learning
i could describe as you know fitted into
that framework somewhere maybe think
some things were generative models
some things were discriminative models
and then
ideas of base and networks as a way to
you know
an awesome tool um to combine expert
knowledge
and then also learning some data are so
incredibly powerful
and it's such a such a great thing
because you can
you can slot into that framework
everything that you already know
uh so i think learning about
probabilistic graphical models you don't
often hear them talk about too much in
machine learning but i think they're the
best thing since sliced bread
that is so cool and i wish there were
better open source packages
to support it so yeah wouldn't have to
write as much good myself but
yeah that's the coolest thing i think in
fact i've got a puzzle
um good one a little optimism
optimization puzzle
that um i tend to ask people if they're
starting as a disadvantage so
what does see what what do you make of
it okay so it's quite a simple one it's
a like an optimization one
might be an interview question um
okay so you work in a factory that
produces mobile phones okay and this
factory has a hundred floors
and you want to determine what height
you can drop the phones from
such they won't break and you can do
an experiment by dropping your phone out
the window
and just seeing if it breaks and then
presumably sending someone downstairs to
pick up the pieces
[Music]
so you could just throw a phone out
every window
um and you know maybe someone thrown a
phone off the very off the roof and it
definitely breaks and someone's put it
on the ground so it definitely doesn't
break so it's somewhere in that range
and you wish to minimize the expected
number of experiments
that you have to do until you've
determined the highest floor
in which the phone won't break when
dropped
so what's your strategy for which floors
do you try
i would imagine you'd have some kind of
a distribution over the floors
and i'm guessing clearly
um on the early floors it probably won't
break and then i would imagine it would
kind of increase
exponentially right but the explanation
is wrong but it would kind of curve up
what most people would do before hearing
about base and stats and
i guarantee this is the answer you get
90 of the time is people will say ah
i've solved it use a binary search tree
you have 450
and then maybe if it's above 75 and then
floor 62
and you halve each time and then you
know two to the seven so you should
always be able to do it in seven
experiments or less
that's the most efficient oh yeah
they've forgotten their prior
they've completely forgotten their prior
knowledge kinetic energy prior
it's almost definitely gonna break from
the first floor so you just do it in one
right like
check out the first four if it it
doesn't break throughout the second it
will definitely break then
um but when presented with that survivor
people forget that prior immediately i
think my value function's broken
i just want to set up a conveyor belt
off the 100th floor and see what happens
see how smash things can get
yeah i'm not going to be checking this
out of any windows
no i have a question for you connor uh
who do you think we should uh interview
next who would you like to see on
machine learning street talk
oh that's a good question
um i think professor daphne caller would
be the most incredible guest to have if
you could get her
from stanford cool okay
well we're going to make it an absolute
josh yeah and
and yeah when we get daphne on you can
take my spot connor
i'll just be gushing the whole time
amazing
well her book is amazing
i have actually come across and
i came across daphne on twitter the
other day this is a coincidence but
um there was a guy at deepmind who said
oh you know like everyone else
he wasn't he wasn't educated exactly he
wasn't educated by
andrew wang and all these new founded
courses he
you know read chris bishop and daphne
collar i'm
sure he said that so i did actually
download that pdf a couple of days ago
and it's fantastic
it's it's free to download isn't it i
think i think so yeah and she's also i
think a co-founder of coursera like
andrew eng so she's a great educator
wow amazing well konatan thank you very
much for joining us this evening it's
been an absolute pleasure
thank you very much for having me
amazing